what's it feel like to know this is
where you're going to be working
now um it's great you know it's great um
I'm really really happy really excited
to be here um I'm thankful I'm
blessed man there's just you know
there's so many things that I want to
say but just you know sums up to you
know thankful to God for this
opportunity and and to to you know to be
traded but then move somewhere like you
know come here and come home it's a
great feeling what was your reaction
when when you found out about the trade
and then ultimately when you heard it
was Toronto yeah first initial reaction
was like what's going on you know I I
like just woke up to it and then um I
mean to to have moved and like I said
coming home I was immediately I was
happy you know I grew up Raptors fan all
my life so to to come here and put this
jersey on it's going to be great are
there any memories that like really
stick out in your mind from growing up
either watching the team being being in
the arena
being a fan um just watching everything
my dad would take me to games when I was
younger um so I I remember watching like
dear and Jose cauldron and uh yeah and
then I remember when KY lar came over
just you know a lot of a lot of early
memories just going to the games you
know being a fan always being excited so
to to be here playing on the court now
is going to be uh it's going to be
different